[Music]
You're an
Alien you're super
powerful recently saved the world when
your
friends what do you like to do for
fun
Vengeance I was thinking more like
reading or or or
yoga hey Buddy isn't it great to finally
relax I am been a kid a
warrior I only remain on Earth because I
made a vow to you and the box so I made
myself at
home nope we are not turning our living
room into some kind of gladiator
fighting pit what is aie doing here he
will be challenging his greatest
enemy is that our
mailman this is not a place of battle so
I will be begin my quest come weed most
people think I'm a joke I do not make
jokes I make
warriors let's go get
him
knuckles without his little friends he's
vulnerable he's the key to power my
newest creation you worked for
Robotnik bring me
knuckles sorry this L is reserved you
think you can take my
power do I look like I need your power
what are you talking about of course we
need his power it's the whole reason
we're
here your
mind I made a promise to protect this
planet I
am ready oh snap someone's about to get
[Applause]
slapped I think today is going to be a
beautiful
day C help me you going to rescue him no
he must learn to rescue
himself
there
[Music]
he